oui ensuite s'il vous plait
sauce
[Musique]
p
technique classique bien sur
encore perfectionné par le maar
satisfait
donc je pense que c'est bien que nous ayons un 8
et des semaines d'essai
les nerfs maintenant nous sommes tous peuvent être
ne doit pas être des filles que nous avons
ici on a déjà une horloge douze ans et
commandes de frappe
tu devras travailler plus fort pour en faire un
situation désespérée
[Musique]
arrosoir client soufflé vous avez encore
assis en comptant jusqu'à votre
traitement hormonal
nous traversons aussi la puberté féminine
possible d'imiter
Alors quels sont les effets
réversible
livre d'épargne john grant examen important
pour nous montrer les reportages des médias youtube
montcalm nous avons le seul péché dedans
c'est un court cognitif maintenant plus de gens
pour comprendre alors précisez hein chaque nom
fruit
[Musique]
peut faire
le code média buzzybee là-dedans sont
la location d'un vélo coûte donc on cherche
[Musique]